a lot of people would come up to me say
you're doing a third round he's doing
the third one but the joke always was
what's it gonna be
Tokyo is falling the sign of Arbor has
fallen to round out the end of summer
how does the heated political action
flick sound Gerard Butler and Morgan
Freeman star in the third installment of
the has fallen franchise angel has
fallen here's everything you need to
know before you go
let's talk about the key players in the
previous two films we've got Gerard
Butler as Mike banning a former US Army
Ranger now a Secret Service agent
Aaron Eckhart as president Benjamin
Asher Morgan Freeman as Speaker of the
House vice-president and acting
president Allen Trumbull and Angela
Bassett as Lynne Jacobs director of The
Secret Service why do people love it in
addition to the heavy hitter actors
people love the franchise for its
boisterous action filled with danger
excitement and thrills whether they're
heroes or villains the stories justify
and explain the motivations of the
clearly defined characters and since
these films are primarily action based
they translate easily across borders
they've grossed more money overseas than
in the US the franchise kicked off with
Olympus has fallen Secret Service agent
Mike banning was assigned to president
Asher and his wife Margaret of which he
had a friendly and personal relationship
as a result of a freaky car accident
first lady margaret was killed Manning
was able to save the president but he
reminded president Asher to much of the
tragedy that took his wife so he was
reassigned to the Treasury Department 18
months later this is the part that kicks
into high gear president Benjamin Asher
along with two other international
officials are held hostage by terrorist
motivated by history and personal
vendettas before dying one of Asher
Secret Service agents alerts director
Lynn Jacobs that Alicia's father
hey that's the name of the movie
banning rejoins the White House defense
to rescue the president and hostages
single-handedly he disables the White
House surveillance and gains access to
president Asher's satellite phone to
communicate with director Jacobson Alan
Trumbull Speaker of the House and now
acting president panics first mission
and done successfully was to rescue
Connor the president's son because he
knew Kang would use him as the
president's weakness after doing so
Bannon goes to work taking out the
terrorists one by one until he gets to
Kang Kang eventually cracked the
president's code to Cerberus which he
needed in order to carry out his plan
millions of Americans will perish no
country will be a cold dawg nuclear
always left after which he attempted to
escape with Asher banning ends Kang in a
one-on-one fight and in the nick of time
disable Cerberus with the help of Acting
President Trumbull the film ends with
banning returning the president hashers
side after saving his life once more now
on to London has fallen once again the
story centers around agent Mike bannings
ability to rescue people and kick ass
two years after a terrorist mastermind
is taken out by a drone strike
banning president Asher and Secret
Service director Jacobs travelled to the
UK for the funeral of the British prime
minister while arriving mercenaries
disguised as police officers attack
different city landmarks civilians and
public officials while the three are
fleeing to safety director Jacobs is
killed and dies in Mike's arms he
promises her he'll get the people
responsible for the devastation Mike
gets in communication with vice
president Trumbull and tells him he and
the president have escaped the chaos and
are alive while in the tunnel the
president tells banning to kill him
because that's what the terrorists want
that's an order banning agrees
reluctantly soon after the White House
staff learns that the Prime Minister was
poisoned and killed in an effort to
bring world leaders together
this was the terrorists plan
sure is abducted in their attempt to get
to the u.s. embassy when Mike regains
consciousness he goes after Asher and
the terrorist with SAS commandos he
saves Asher just before the terrorists
try to enact his execution on live TV
with the president now safe two weeks
later mike is at home with his wife and
newborn baby
he considers handing in his letter of
resignation but something stops him
what's the news story former vice
president Allen Trumbull has been
elected president banning enjoyed a
cordial relationship with Trumbull in
the past but now finds himself under
suspicion of an assassination attempt
upon the president bannings own agency
along with the FBI pursues him believing
him to be guilty forcing him to join
forces with unexpected allies to clear
his name and identify the guilty parties
how is this one different from the
others let's have the cast tell us angel
has fallen is what Logan was two x-men a
much more personal journey where the
rest of what's going on is really in the
back you know we're really seeing all
her struggles his strange relationship
with his father who abandoned him when
he was a kid fugitive style journey of a
guy who we know and love now and the
most peril these films what defines them
is actually it's like a roller coaster
if you give them that up and rest period
and it's got substance to it you can get
a drop
that's what fascinated me so now you
know and now you can go see angel has
fallen August 23rd